heavenly shades of knife are falling
it's twilight
wonder and vision aren't we a five pack
this is our home now i want us to fit in
oh this is gonna be a gaff happy new
year my fellow nerds
now that our no marvel year is finally
over
it's time to celebrate the first foray
into the marvel disney plus universe is
juan division and over the weekend i had
the chance to talk to stars elizabeth
olsen
and paul bettany about what fans can
expect from the nine episode series
it was kind of intimidating you know to
to be especially since black widow
wasn't able to be released to be the
first that fans
have um have seen and
um i feel very lucky because this is a
really
unique and fresh and new way of telling
um our superhero story and uh
it was a blast because of how how
different
it was my hope for this show is that it
brings in a lot of new fans through the
sort of nostalgia
of those shows but also
i think it's incredibly satisfying the
latter half of the
series really will
for for people who have been following
marvel
uh it really is going to pack a big
punch
and they will they will recognize that
world
and it will make them look at that world
in a whole new light suddenly and i am
i i think for died in the wool marvel
fans
it's going to be a really uh it's going
to reveal a lot of stuff about the
future
so now that we know probably about the
same as we did
before you just saw those clips i'm
gonna fill you in
on everything else you need to know
before one division premieres
on disney plus january 15th
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so first things first when does one
division take place now aside from
knowing that the new series takes place
in a world
after the events of avengers and game
your guess is as good as ours as to what
exact year wanda and vision are in
and we don't know exactly how much time
has passed since wanda was snapped
back into existence and certainly no
idea what year that corresponds to
in the new mcu timeline this place
i don't understand what's happening what
we do know
is that marvel loves a good setup and
one division has been confirmed as the
precursor to doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
so it's assumed the show takes place
somewhere in between the two films
now that we sort of have a when let's
talk about the where
and they lived happily ever after
we know from the trailers and clips that
one division's trippy aesthetic comes
from a desire to pay homage
to different eras of sitcom tv with the
first two episodes actually being filmed
in front of a live studio audience i
love lucy's style
they are an unusual couple you know oh i
don't think that was ever in question
there will likely be a plot related
reason for all the sitcom aesthetics
a theory has already been suggested that
it has to do with wanda's reality
altering powers that has
somehow been inspired by watching tv and
another one suggests an evil force is
creating this alternate reality
cruelly designed to resemble an idyllic
life with vision who tragically died at
the end of infinity war
didn't he
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are
oh yeah vision's dead so how was he
alive in one division now if you
remember
thanos plucked the mind stone straight
from vision's head destroying his
consciousness
and leaving his body in the wakandan
dirt
so the theory behind this is directly
linked to the reason the show might look
like a variety of sitcoms one division
could be a result of a grieving wanda
bringing vision back to life
using her powers to create a false
reality where her robo-bow
is alive and well now who will be
joining elizabeth olsen and paul bettany
in the series hiya kids
auntie agnes is here and i've got a
couple of tricks up my sleeve
uh let's just take it from the top
[Laughter]
catherine han who is regularly the best
part of anything she's in is peppered
throughout the trailers as
everything from a nosy neighbor to a
literal tackling witch
now the actress is credited as nosy
neighbor but eagle-eyed marvel fans are
speculating
that she's actually playing agatha
harkness
so when someone says to you like have
you read the theory about the fact that
you're actually agatha harkness
and you're going to be abc exclusive you
just grab that glass and you're like
honey i'm the nosy neighbor who lives
next door
who is in there who is in their
neighborhood as a confidant
of wanda to guide her through
the michigan which is life in this new
neighborhood
introduced in the comic book world back
in the 1970s agatha the harkness was
originally a character from the
fantastic four franchise
first appearing in fantastic four number
94 as a nanny to franklin richards reed
and sue's son
now franklin coincidentally also has
reality altering powers
that is an entire different bucket
of universes okay fast forward to
avengers number 128
where agatha transitions to the avengers
and then that issue
actually saves wanda and vision before
revealing her plan to teach the scarlet
witch
the waves of magic are you here to help
us
this is our home then let's fight for it
die hard comic fans will remember that
it's not until
agatha's death in the comics
specifically the vision and scarlet
witch
volume 2 number 3 where an apparition of
agatha tells wanda
to really use her magic which wanda
takes as a hint to use her magic
to create the children that her and
vision
long for wanda have you gotten bigger
life lives pretty fast out in the
suburbs
yes those are twin babies and yes they
are wanda and visions children but why
are they so important well a deep dive
into the comics reveals that the twins
are actually shards of another
character's soul
stay with me now what character is this
it's mephisto
and if you're asking who me fisto is
well you're gonna have to wait until
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness to find out unless
you read the comics in which case
we already know wanda what's up
who are you i don't know
now back to the cast of wand division
johnny paris is playing someone who
marvel fans are
definitely going to know mom it's auntie
carol
i knew it everyone said you were dead
but we knew they were lying
i'm not really who you think i am fans
will remember a young monica rambo from
2019's captain marvel but in true marvel
style
the show's creators are staying
tight-lipped about how rambo is going to
fit into west view
guess what so is tiana how excited are
you
for the fans to watch this show and and
kind of have to
go on the journey with you because
oftentimes we as comic fans think we
know
you know what's coming up next right um
i'm i'm really excited because the fans
have definitely been um
tweeting me and engaging me on instagram
and they're letting me know that they're
waiting and i i'm really excited for
what you know the future holds for
monica in the mcu
but her history is just so rich in the
comic books that they could pull from
anywhere and so it will be a surprise
and exciting to all of us
yeah it's cool to finally see a grown-up
version of monica in one division
as the character has a long history in
the comics monica was the first black
female avenger frequently fighting
alongside wanda and vision
she has a boatload of heroic names as
well including photon
pulsar spectrum and captain marvel
and that's right in the comics monica
rambo was the first woman to use the
moniker
predating carol danvers
we just don't know what twix back so
there you have it friends if you've made
it this far
chances are you know everything you need
to know before you enjoy one division
keep it locked to et canada's youtube
page to join me every week
as we break down the biggest easter eggs
and reveals from the show and new
episodes
of et canada's nerd alert see ya